hello welcome to this video playing
Peregrine 64 so I'm playing the exchange
variation I kind of did he didn't he
play that against me at some point
sometimes you have those memory flashes
I think that that's the case actually ok
anyway here we get this ending I do know
that all too all too well I have the
same it would seem 96 will come mouse is
played I ridden away formerly in a 45 g5
holy moly
and it looks a little bit strange for me
to be honest that looks a bit strange
a night h4 I mean I can go to g3 but
looks a little bit strange
c5 okay he wants to stop my deform yeah
okay let's stop his be porn first f5 the
move that could be problematic in the
future I wonder ever should take there
and play a form just to get rid of all
that hmm the look that looks wrong okay
looked in one also on yeah feels like
there was room for improvement my ideas
before now takes Knight eggs and then
Luke takes before maybe i'm not in that
bad shape but i don't like how this
unfolded okay i can still take one g5 in
case of f5 I have to watch out for that
doesn't team he has to take now
basically that that's not so bad right
on rook c8 I can go see for and I have
pressure against b7 hmm that looks like
i am fairly okay
wow what does that work I can take it
you see how some made or I don't see it
I'm sorry don't see it
I can take now the age 40 immediately
and i think immediately age four let's
do inch for its ok this is a safe
construction down on the King side and I
can play on the on the queenside
currently mb7 hangs and if he goes route
b8 rugby sixes real pain I take sage
form I didn't want to allow threat new
group chase a six
black resigns John doesn't doesn't look
good anymore yeah I think and though the
opening result was bad for sure really
showing my lack of experience in this
position so him if he got this g5 and
that was probably an achievement from
luck ignitee 6a he's blocking the whole
Kings side I mean at least I felt like I
limited the damage yeah rook t1 here I
was still thinking I take and play play
this but okay he went here and then I
readjusted to them to be one I think
this is probably not a bad idea yeah now
the position is shifting to my favor ey
this better and now winning very
stranger so what did he do wrong maybe
c5 maybe this is a mistake or something
something later Tim the computer
dislikes king is 6 it wants to play rook
c8 which is of course this is a
high-class prophylactic move so this is
this is actually attacking here
interesting yeah after that it was here
it was already tricky and after a five
it was losing this line is I think
pretty good for black not advise not an
advantage you cannot get an advantage
against the exchange we but I think and
it's a good good try to equalize and do
that in a way that they're still play
left so as we had seen I think he
definitely had a very good position ok
guys thanks for watching